What protocell formula is recommended for metastatic breast cancer, or does it depend on where the cancer has metastasized?
I have survived stage 3 breast cancer with protocell diet and detox methods.
My husband is a pharmaceutical doctor and has recommended protocell to some of his patients as well.
My regimen in 2007-2012 was no supplement or food high in vitamin C.
I am understanding that you recommend if a person chooses to eat or take these between protocell dosages.
Is this a more recent change in your program?
We have a friend who has recently diagnosed with metastatic breast cancer that is considering this treatment method as opposed to doing your chemo.
For those who don't know what protocell is, protocell is a natural product that is used for cancer.
It is an oxidizing agent.
I will touch on this briefly, but you can find out more about antioxidants in my blog.
Everybody has heard of antioxidants.
The truth is that you have oxidation that takes place within your body.
We can't get too hung up on that oxidative stress is all bad because it's not.
Everything that happens in your body has to have a balance.
Oxidative stress causes this, oxidative stress causes this.
Well, that's true, but oxidative stress is also produced in your body to kill bacteria, to kill viruses, to kill microbes in your body.
Oxidative stress is produced as a side note in other metabolic activity, and then you typically produce antioxidants to deal with that.
But we can easily get hung up on that.
Everybody needs to be taking antioxidants.
The truth is that cancer patients should really be careful in taking antioxidants.
In my book, I write that cancer patients shouldn't be taking antioxidants at all.
And why?
Because cancer is cells that are in rapid replication.
Because they're in rapid replication, they're not replicating super-healthy cells.
The mitochondria of the cells aren't functioning real well.
Therefore, you're not making a lot of glutathione, which is your main intercellular antioxidant.
And cancer cells themselves are under a lot of oxidative stress.
So if you can picture it like that, a cell has a possible lethal dose level, if you could put it on a graph.
A lethal dose level of oxidative stress, if it reaches that lethal dose of oxidative stress, it's going to implode and die, it's going to cause lysis of the cell and destruction of the cell.
Well, cancer cells are really close to that lethal dose.
A healthy cell isn't healthy cells producing glutathione, getting rid of oxidative agents, reactive oxygen, species, reactive nitrogen, species, fairly effectively.
And this person is, that cell is staying fairly healthy.
Cancer cells, rapidly replicating, are not producing a lot of glutathione, are not getting rid of oxidative stress.
Because they're producing rapidly, they're producing more oxidative stress.
So they're real close to that threshold of a lethal dose of oxidative stress.
Now, we can harness that. So that's what chemotherapy is.
This is the grudge that alternative doctors had against chemotherapy.
Here come, it's like chemotherapy is a poison. Why would you put this poison in your body?
Well, in true definition, chemotherapy is a poison because it's an oxidizing agent.
So, any poison is an oxidizing agent at a certain dose.
So, yes, we're giving an oxidizing agent to a cancer patient.
Well, why does that even make sense? Why would you give a cancer patient a cortical poison?
It makes all the sense of the world from physiology because you're dealing with a cell line,
this cancer that is growing and growing and growing and possibly metastasizing,
that is at close to threshold of lethal death of oxidative stress.
How can we just tip it over a little bit? It helped that cancer cell die.
Well, we could give it chemotherapy. That's how chemotherapy works.
We're going to give it just a little bit more lethal dose of oxidative stress,
an oxidizing agent to hopefully tip that over and kill the cancer.
Well, the truth is, is that we could do that also with natural needs,
and I touch on four different nutrients in that article.
Melatone, Delta, Tokofriedol, Vitamin E, Selenium, and Vitamin C.
At a certain dose, all those things that I just mentioned would be considered.
If you looked at antioxidants, Vitamin E is an antioxidant, Selenium is an antioxidant,
Melatone is an antioxidant, Vitamin C is an antioxidant.
There's many, but I just touched on those four in that article.
But what has been discovered is that at a higher dose of those nutrients,
they actually work as oxidizing agents on cancer cells.
And interestingly, they don't cause oxidation of healthy cells, kind of cool, huh?
So, higher dose melatonin, like typically you take three milligrams of melatonin to help you fall asleep at night.
Maybe six. That's about the dose of melatonin that you would use.
But doses of 40, 60, 80, 100 milligrams of melatonin,
even up to 200 milligrams of melatonin, have found to be oxidizing to cancer cells.
And can be that tipping point to cause that extra level of oxidative stress in a cancer cell
for it to reach the lethal dose of oxidative stress caused down,
similar to what chemotherapy does.
Well, there's other nutrients that have been on the market for a number of years.
One of them is protocell. That's an oxidized agent for cancer cell.
Leandro is another thing.
That's an oxidized agent for cancer cell, D17.
There's numerous oxidized agents for cancer cells that we use.
Now, I am said with some people, so we do cheek swab testing with our patients.
Some people test well for antioxidants as well.
So I typically, if they test well for antioxidants, if they test for protocell,
then I have them take the antioxidants, that's what this question is about, between doses.
But really, for the most part, most of my patients,
I do not recommend that they take antioxidants that have cancer,
because you are typically treating them with higher dose of those things,
or protocell, or B17, or something else that is an oxidizing agent,
so that we're hard to see that the same thing as chemotherapy.
And interestingly, studies were done on these things with a person beat on chemotherapy, too.
So it actually can help the chemotherapy work better as well.
So bottom line is, the question is, what protocell formula,
because there's two formulas of protocell, protocell 23 and protocell 50,
which you recommend, prevent aesthetic breast cancer.
Well, honestly, we test people for that.
So we get a cheek swab, a test people for that.
In general, I think more with breast cancer, it'd be more formula 23,
with prostate cancer, it'd be more likely to be formula 50,
but that's all I could say as far as in general goes with that.
But in general, too, with treating cancer anyway,
you don't want to be antioxidants.
Or if you're on an antioxidant like vitamin C is an antioxidant,
if you're taking it at a higher dose, it's an oxidizing agent.
So just be taking it at a higher dose, don't be taking it at a low dose vitamin C.